so in a funny way hyper instruments I
keep talking about the Beatles and I
think maybe it's because sergeant
pepper's came out when I was about 13 or
14 and I was a pretty impression of olay
age and things you know it was such a
kind of radical period but that period
of the Beatles really had a big
influence on me and I think are directly
related to hyper instruments so here an
album like sergeant pepper's comes out
incredibly new sounds layer upon layer
of studio produced sound like nothing
anybody had ever done before and it's
also the period where the Beatles
realize that what they were making in
the studio could never be performed
they'd already been getting tired they'd
already kind of given up on performing
because there were too many screaming
fans and they were playing in larger and
larger venues so they couldn't even hear
what they were playing it just wasn't
fun anymore at the same time their music
evolved to something that they get only
put together in a multitrack recording
studio so I think so many things about
that period in the late 60s stuck with
me the sense of I mean I love the cello
I love this physical sense of an
instrument that's about the size of your
body that vibrates enough so that even
if you play an open string you know you
feel it I mean you really feel it from
your toes to your you know hair
follicles and you know it really uses
your your money I mean you have to put a
fair amount of effort into the
instruments that I mean I think a double
bass for me would be like too much
effort but but the cello you know you're
really engaged and the sound is kind of
right here so it feels like being merged
married to an instrument I like that
feeling and I like the idea of imagining
a sound and feeling a sound and then
having it come out through your body
through an instrument like that so
that's an important way to make music
then you have something like the Beatles
making this great music where they say
you know we just give up we can't we're
never going to perform this it's not
just that we're not going to go on tour
right now this music has too many layers
it's got you know
too many changes in the sound you know
the this voice is getting old sudden
gets prominent and then it disappears
and and this is its final version you
also have at the same exactly the same
years I never thought of that but 1967
Glenn Gould the great pianist wrote an
article called the future of recording
and that was exactly the period where
Glenn Gould said I'm never going to play
in public anymore you know I don't first
of all I'm kind of shy and I don't like
man just makes me uncomfortable to play
in front of people plus I want to get my
performances exactly right you know I
imagine precisely the way these
different lines in the Bach fugue need
to be balanced and I understand you know
exactly the relationship of this voice
to that one and yes I can play it but I
want to go in and adjust these things in
the recording studio and and that's my
new medium recording is the future
that's funny so golden beetles did that
the same year and I think what's stuck
with me at that point was wow I totally
I love this music and I totally get it
and here's google doing it for Bach and
the Beatles doing it with their music
but they're not performing anymore and I
love performing you know I think that
one of the things about music is that
it's supposed to be spontaneous it's
supposed to be real human beings
bouncing off each other where whether
it's from the stage to the audience or
jamming with friends I mean I love the
idea you know it's important as a
composer to be able to sit in silence
and imagine these complex musical worlds
in your head but it's also a wonderful
experience to touch your music and to
you know to hear it and hear it in the
room with you and to say like you know
you can't have an entire Orchestra there
but you kind of like to have the
orchestra there you'd like musicians
playing for you and you'd like to say oh
you know what duh I need 10 more French
horns or you know that just doesn't work
right I need some instrument that
doesn't exist you want to go back and
forth between the sound and touching it
so I think from that very early time age
13 14 15 I thought yes
rich studio produced music is the future
but it can't be the future to go run
away into the recording studio you know
how can we take that kind of complexity
and richness and make it possible for
people to touch it and play it live that
that's what hyper instruments are so I
took a while for I think the seed was
planted when I was a teenager and it was
really it took me until I got out of
Juilliard at Juilliard I was just
learning to be a composer but I was also
learning how to manipulate computers so
nobody at Juilliard this is kind of in
the mid to late 70s nobody was
interested in computers then it was kind
of too late for moge synthesizers and
there were a few computers around the
world in like Stanford University and
MIT and Princeton were Columbia
University about the only ones where you
could you know you used punch cards and
you'd go in and type out your computer
program to make notes appear and I mean
this is what I learned how to do when i
was at Juilliard i found somebody at
columbia taught me how to do this I go
to the City University Graduate Center
here in Manhattan type out the punch
cards for maybe 30 seconds of music that
I wanted to let's say play for a string
quartet that looked at my music and
thought it was completely crazy and
unplayable and I said no though it
sounds really good I'm gonna put it on
you know so so you made the punch cards
a week later I'd go back and pick up a
reel-to-reel tape and put it on the tape
recorder and of course you couldn't edit
it you couldn't see the notation you
have is ridiculous but I learned that at
Juilliard and then when I went to Paris
in 1978 this ear calm Institute had just
opened up at the Pompidou Center and for
the first time there was really money
around and people around to think about
really bringing musicians and scientists
and technologists together was like I
was very lucky to be there at that time
was really great and they were just
starting to invent computers that worked
fast enough to give you music
immediately so instead of waiting a week
to get your music back you could you
still have to write software there were
no there was no
graphics but you'd write some software
say okay now and it would play your
piece and then you might be able to do a
carriage return it would make it louder
or softer it was very primitive but it
was immediate and that's when I started
thinking about these hyper instruments
you know wow you could you could have
the best of both worlds you could you
could have layer upon layer and and and
delicate sound and voices and
instruments and sounds nobody you've
ever heard you can mix them all together
but I can put them in a laboratory I
could put them in a studio so that
they'll play back immediately and if I
can touch a key and have something
happen I should be able to make my own
instrument I should be able to make
something where I can squeeze something
or you know the way I touch something
should be able to change the sound so I
started thinking about either leveraging
off of existing instruments or making
new instruments that would take what
people do well in mastering an
instrument but multiplying the effect
that you could produce with that
instrument so I didn't actually build a
hyper instrument until i moved to MIT in
1985 because at that point personal
computers had just come out so you could
do all kinds of things with a you know a
two-thousand-dollar box and anyway there
are a lot of things that happen in the
mid 80s that all of a sudden made it
possible to do a lot of very quick
interactive music and with the hyper
instrument the idea was how to take the
act of performing how to measure what a
performer is playing but also how
they're playing what the interpretation
is and let that interpretation be the
equivalent of five recording engineers
in the Beatles digital recording studio
instead of a bunch of people moving
knobs up and down and pushing buttons to
change that effect and saying oh let's
add that you simply do it by playing
your instrument and if you if you play
the downbeat of certain measure louder
or if I play this phrase building up the
intensity to this section or if I lay
off and it all becomes very calm if I
change I'm all showing as if I'm playing
but the Chelle is not a bad way of
thinking about it because you can change
all kinds of qualitative aspects of the
sound if I'm playing a note and it goes
from
you if i change that kind of quality of
sound I started to measure those kind of
things so that that sound might mean
okay if I make that transition then I
want to change the cello without a cello
anymore it's a voice or its or it's
something I've never heard before or if
I use this part of the bow and play with
certain accents I'm going to play a
melody in and depending on the way I
play it's going to add its own harmony
so the instrument a single person
playing an instrument could make the
equivalent of a multitrack recording and
by interpreting the music differently in
as natural way as possible I could shape
the way this sounded not like being at a
mixing desk in a recording studio not
like writing a computer program not like
working with the machine but just like
playing naturally so that's what I
wanted a hyper instrument to be
especially for trained musicians
so one of the interesting things about
inventing these instruments and actually
the in some ways the more unusual the
instruments are that you think of or the
sounds you think of the more radical the
technology is that you're trying to
develop for music in particular the more
likely it is that something unexpected
is going to come out of it that you
didn't expect at the beginning so it's a
perfect case we built this hyper cello
for yo-yo MA and you know I wanted to
keep it as close to a regular cello as
possible so had a regular fingerboard
regular strings yo-yo is a really nice
guy but when I started talking about
taping or nailing things onto a
Stradivarius he didn't like that idea
too much so so we made a physical
instrument from scratch so we could put
measurement devices and sensors right in
the instrument so you play this cello
you plug it in it can sound like a
regular cello but it's also measuring
everything that's happening then we took
a regular bow because measuring the
Boeing for cello is is like breathing
for a singer so we had to measure
everything about the you have a
horsehair on the string and the how the
pressure and how fast it's moving in the
angle we found out the best way to do
that was to put two computer chips on
either side of the bow to send
electricity through the chips into the
air to put a little antenna on the cello
the antenna picks up the electricity and
it can tell if you write software which
side of the bow the electricity is
coming from and by doing that you could
tell where the bow is how fast it's
moving how much bow you're using which
part of the bow you're on the angle
everything you need to to have a kind of
language of the gesture of bowing so we
did that it worked well I wrote some
pieces for yo-yo he played them and so
that kind of hyper cello started taking
off at the same time we were rehearsing
and we found that when yo-yos bow got
close to the cello when his hand got
close to the cello the measurement went
all wacky it wasn't supposed to do that
so we went back to the lab we found out
that sure enough his body was absorbing
electricity from
this circuit which is kind of a drag
because you know it became unpredictable
so first we figured out how to modify it
so you could predict it but then I
started thinking oh gee if this electric
circuit is is measuring where you know
how much electricity is hand is
absorbing it actually knows what I could
tell where his hand is and if I could do
that I can actually throw away the cello
and throw away the bow and just make an
instrument that measures the way
somebody moves their hands and so a
light bulb went off and I started
thinking my gosh all the sophisticated
software for measuring how yo yo plays
and how he moves and this technique of
the bow I should be able to use similar
techniques for measuring the way anybody
moves and so somebody who's not a
professional or trained musician I
should be able to make a musical
environment for them so the first
instrument we made after the hyper cello
was a chair we made something called the
sensor chair and we actually made this
with for the magicians Penn and Teller
because they were following the work and
we kind of had this idea so he took a
chair put a piece of metal on the chair
when you sit on the chair your rear end
touches the metal and your body becomes
part of this electric circuit just like
the the bow was so electricity is
streaming out of your body you put two
poles in front of the chair and the
polls have sensors in them with little
lights so when I move my arms I'm
electricity's coming out of my arms and
these sensors can tell how much
electricity is in the air so again if I
write software it knows exactly where my
hands are and it also if I'm smart
enough i can write software it knows am
i moving in it jagged way am i moving
smoothly am i moving continuously am i
moving discontinuously so there are all
kinds of qualities I can pick up so we
made actually a musical instrument and
then a little opera magic trick for Penn
and Teller which was based on sitting
sitting on this chair and playing
melodies and harmonies and rhythms just
by moving your hands and it was it was
great I sort of thought of it as a
virtuosic instrument for anybody I mean
everybody can move their hands but you
kind of have to sit down learn where the
sounds are learn how to shape them learn
how to communicate this to somebody
so it was a real breakthrough and we
started making a lot of instruments for
the general public we did a big project
at Lincoln Center for the Lincoln Center
festival called the brain opera where he
made a whole Orchestra of about 75
instruments about 10 different models we
called it the mind forest we filled up
the lobby of the Juilliard theatre and
people would come in you'd be surrounded
with this web of instruments like a
driving game where you could drive
musical notes through of pathways
depending on how you drove the music
would change table tops where you can
move your fingers and change the music
big walls where you could move your
whole body same electricity system to
change big masses of sound percussion
instruments that you you know looked
like these rubber organic pads hundreds
of them all over the room so the
audience got to experiment with these
and we put on a performance every hour
of the brain opera but a half of it was
prepared by me ahead of time half of it
we took from what the audience had just
done with these instruments it was a
collaboration through these instruments
with the audience and around that time I
had a lot of really interesting students
in my group a lot of them have gone on
to do really really interesting things
in in all these kinds of areas how to
make music accessible to the general
public a couple of these students
started a company right near MIT it's
still there companies called harmonics
and they started you know taking these
same especially this idea of a driving
game where I could drive a musical note
through a series of roads they actually
took some joysticks and had a piece of
music that would play and depending on
how you moved if you moved the right
joystick it would push this music to
different harmonies if you move the left
joystick it would make the rhythm more
complex so just by moving the joysticks
anybody could modify this music and they
did work like that for about seven or
eight years now they made some games
that were kind of okay I mean there are
actually very good games they didn't
sell all that much and then somebody
came to them and said you ever think of
using you know making a plastic guitar
and
what would it be like if it took exactly
the same software and had somebody with
the qatari interface instead of these
joysticks so we all talked about that
they made this game called guitar hero
and nobody expected it to be a success
and actually when guitar hero first came
out the big like Best Buy and Target in
all those places bought very few of them
but the fact that it was a guitar
interface and not joysticks people had
imagined so many people had imagined
what it would feel like to play guitar
and the gameplay the idea that it wasn't
just moving music around with joysticks
but you were being graded at how
accurate you were and it was very easy
to tell how well you were doing you know
we did as we know it became a success
very fast so so that came directly out
of the out of the work on the bow and
the cello and that turning into this
sensor chair and all that softer went
into harmonics and is now out there was
guitar hero in rock band